pulling off moves like this
takes concentration
but staying focused when your family
back home is suffering because of a
military invasion is far from easy
that's the challenge facing ukraine's
artistic gymnasts who are training in
qatar after a recent competition here
bogdan machutz is an olympic gold
medalist
he tours with ukraine's competitors as a
judge and is doing his best to help them
through these difficult times
this week has been a bit easier than
last week we were giving the youngsters
work to distract them from the thoughts
that for the moment we are unable to
return home we are trying to make sure
that they are not thinking about
problems
there's been some controversy during the
ukrainian stay in qatar participants
from russia were allowed to compete at
last week's event in doha as neutrals
one russian gymnast
stood on the podium next to a ukrainian
with the letter zed on his chest a
symbol of support for the russian
invasion of ukraine
what he did is his issue our goal is to
compete russia has been forbidden to use
their logo and anthem because of what
they are doing against our country this
is all their fault we are trying to
compete decently
qatar has paid for the gymnasts to
extend their stay in the country and the
local ukrainian community has also
offered its support
by our position as a ukrainian community
we do our best to support them at least
in the some free time
during the week it's absolutely
impossible they do have a whole day
training session
and for them it's no possibility to rest
or to see the city so on the sunday we
want to organize our community and to
show them the city the ukrainian
gymnasts will be leaving qatar in a few
days for a competition in egypt but the
real big one is the world championship
in liverpool which begins in october
they'll be hoping that by then there'll
be peace back in their homeland suhail
malik al-jazeera doha